rischioso parlare di gravidanza per
questo comincia proprio così avvisandovi
ci sono donne che vogliono restare
incinta e purtroppo non ci riescono
altre che invece restano incinta senza
volerlo si stima che circa il 50 per
cento delle gravidanze siano un
pianificato altre volte la gravidanza è
il risultato traumatico di una violenza
sessuale
altre volte ancora una coppia appena
finito l'ultimo ciclo di fecondazione
assistita che poteva permettersi quando
parlo di gravidanza non parlo solo alle
donne ma anche agli uomini supporre che
una persona debba voglia addirittura
possa concepire dei bambini solo in base
al proprio genere e invadente e
presuntuoso il 25 per cento delle
gravidanze termina con un aborto
spontaneo
una donna su quattro una coppia su
quattro
questo vuol dire che ogni volta che sui
social media vediamo tre coppie
annunciare una gravidanza
c'è una persona a casa una donna una
coppia che non ha potuto fare quella
quello stesso annuncio quando viviamo un
lutto siamo soliti parlarne con la
nostra famiglia con i nostri cari coi
nostri amici addirittura sui social
questo ci permette di ricevere il
supporto necessario per superare quello
che è un evento traumatico
ciò però non è valido per gli aborti
spontanei l'aborto resta un evento
solitario e segreto dove le donne e le
coppie sono isolate dalla regola del
delle dodici settimane mi presento
nuovamente mi chiamo erica e l'anno
scorso ha perso un bambino parlare di
aborti spontanei e difficile
è personale e triste ma non è raro o
innaturale
quando l'anno scorso ho scoperto che la
mia gravidanza non sarebbe andata a buon
fine mi sono di è stata per non averne
parlato con nessuno ho dovuto chiamare i
miei genitori primi amiche e annunciare
ero incinta non lo sono più
questo rende ovviamente il discorso
difficile perché mi sono sentita
invisibile non abbastanza inadeguata
quante altre donne si sono sentite così
come me proprio perché isolate da questa
regola delle dodici settimane la
conoscete
secondo la regola delle dodici settimane
quello che una donna una coppia dovrebbe
fare e annunciare la gravidanza
solo al termine della dodicesima
settimana di gestazione
quando la gravidanza è fuori pericolo
quindi quando il rischio di aborto
spontaneo
scende attenzione non si azzera
ma diminuisce drasticamente questa
regola delle dodici settimane mi piace
includerla in quelle che io chiamo fake
life rolls le fake life rose sono quelle
bugie che ci raccontiamo e con cui
cresciamo credendo che siano vere volete
qualche esempio dell università laureati
trova la persona giusta sposa ti fai
figli e via dicendo
ogni generazione ha le sue all'interno
di queste regole c'è anche tutta una
serie di regole che toccano quella che è
la donna è la realtà femminile non ci si
aspetta che una donna parli del suo
essere donna geologicamente parlando non
si aspetta che si parli di aborti o di
mestruazioni e via dicendo
una donna al giorno d'oggi ma anche nel
passato affronta diverse sfide sociali
economiche e sanitarie
quando queste sfide si intersecano
quello che può fare è trovare un
ambiente sociale avverso e che cosa
succede che anche la gravidanza diventa
un banco di prova la gravidanza diventa
il posto in cui rappresentare se stessa
quanto valgo che cosa sono
ma che cosa succede se una donna un
figlio non lo vuole a vedere se una
coppia ha un figlio non lo vuole avere
che cosa succede quando una persona ci
dice che non vuole avere un figlio più
comunemente tutti cominciano a chiedere
perché perché allora non chiediamo a
tutte quelle persone che vogliono
diventare genitori o che lo sono già
perché vogliono esserlo tanto quanto
chiediamo alle persone che non vogliono
esserlo perché non vogliono farlo
viviamo in una società prestazionale in
cui sembra che l'unica cosa importante
sia che lavoro facciamo quanto
guadagniamo che scuole abbiamo fatto con
quanto abbiamo preso a al diploma alla
maturità sembra tutto così falso
sembra quasi che dobbiamo un po
rispecchiare quella che è la pubblicità
del mulino bianco
non è forse così
e cosa succede quando anche un figlio
diventa un obiettivo da raggiungere
quando anche quel figlio rientra nella
stile nella lista di fake life rus che
dobbiamo raggiungere che ci sentiamo un
fallimento che ci sentiamo inadeguati
che sentiamo invisibili che non ci
sentiamo all'altezza è stato terapeutico
per me raccontare quella che è stata la
mia esperienza di aborto spontaneo e
soprattutto comprendere che ci sono
diverse versioni che ogni persona alla
propria narrativa per liberarci da
quelle che sono le oppressioni i tabù
quello che dobbiamo fare forse solo
accettare che ogni persona abbia la
propria storia da raccontare
qualunque essa sia e soprattutto che gli
stereotipi debbano crollare come
possiamo far crollare gli stereotipi
restando all'ascolto
accettando che ogni persona ci può
raccontare la propria storia rendendo
gli altri meno invisibili e soprattutto
accettare che non esiste un solo modo di
essere madre donna può essere umano
grazie